we begin tonight with a huge win for
President Trump the US Supreme Court has
let stand the president's travel ban on
people from five mostly Muslim countries
and two others the White House had
framed the rule as crucial for national
security opponents called it religious
discrimination my colleague in Ankara
fox news at night shannon bream is at
the Supreme Court where she's been all
day with what happened and why along
with the implications going forward
Univision hello Brad well the majority
made clear today that the president was
well within his powers under the law to
set the conditions for people who want
to come to this country it's a victory
for them today but this case is actually
not over after more than a year of legal
wrangling losses in the lower courts and
three different versions the president's
so-called travel ban has been upheld in
a five-to-four opinion by the US Supreme
Court writing for the majority Chief
Justice Roberts said quote by its plain
language federal law grants the
president broad discretion to suspend
the entry of aliens into the United
States the president lawfully exercised
that discretion based on his findings
following a worldwide multi-agency
review that entry of the covered aliens
would be detrimental to the national
interest what we're doing is looking at
countries in a rational way I defy
anybody to tell me that any of the
countries name
that that the government is control that
the vetting process works and terrorism
is not problem what the majority didn't
do was look to the various statements
President Trump made as both a candidate
and newly sworn-in commander-in-chief to
decide whether the van was motivated by
religious animus the Chief Justice again
quote the proclamation is expressly
premise on legitimate purposes the text
says nothing about religion but in one
of two passionate dissents justice
Sotomayor blasted the majority for not
looking to mr. Trump's statements quote
based on the evidence in the record a
reasonable observer would conclude that
the proclamation was motivated by
anti-muslim animus the majority holds
otherwise by ignoring the facts
misconstruing our legal precedent and
turning a blind eye to the pain and
suffering the proclamation inflicts upon
countless families and individuals this
is really a sad day for America make no
mistake the Supreme Court has endorsed
bigotry and Islamophobia the majority
and descent also sparred over
comparisons to Korematsu a 1944 ruling
upholding a presidential directive
ordering japanese-americans into
internment camps in World War two
justice Sotomayor claiming the
majority's reasoning today paralleled
that decision for more than seven
decades ago writing in Korematsu the
court gave a pass to an odious gravely
injurious racial classification
authorized by an executive order the
Chief Justice explicitly rejected the
comparison quote whatever rhetorical
advantage the dissent may see in doing
so Korematsu has nothing to do with this
case it is wholly an apt to liken that
morally repugnant order to a facially
neutral policy denying certain foreign
nationals the privilege of admission and
the case doesn't end here because the
Supreme Court was specifically ruling on
whether or not an injunction against the
travel ban 3.0 could stand so now today
with this guidance from the justices it
goes back to the lower court for a
decision actually on the merits Bret
Chen there was also another ruling today
regarding crisis pregnancy centers in
California how did that pan out well the
state there passed a law that they
managed to scoop up all the pro-life
pregnancy centers almost all of them in
the state essentially telling them
they had to provide all kinds of
information to potential clients
including about where they could find
abortions and access them well these
clinics sued saying that violates their
free speech rights and said it's
actually in antithetical to the mission
that they have which is to encourage
women to carry their pregnancies to term
it was a 5-4 decision written by
Clarence Thomas he essentially found
that it's a good chance these clinics
are going to prevail on the merits so he
sent back the case to California for
them to deal with that crap still
waiting on one more we are tomorrow
we're waiting on a big case involving
whether or not public sector employees
can be forced to pay fees or dues into a
union whose political messages they
don't agree with it could impact
millions of people across the country
we'll get it at 10 a.m. tomorrow morning
another big day shannon bream outside
the court Shannon thanks